o herpes labial é causado pelo vírus
herpes simples e se transmite
principalmente pelo contato direto com
lesões de pessoas infectadas como
durante um beijo os sintomas incluem
lesões na pele ao redor dos lábios
vermelhidão pequenas bolhas amareladas
que causam formigamento e dor além de
febre malestar e dor de garganta já a
candidiase popularmente conhecida como
sapinho é causada por um fungo do gênero
Cândida está ligada à imunidade baixa
começam com uma lesão avermelhada ou
esbranquiçada na língua que pode ou não
doer já a mononucleose conhecida como a
doença do beijo é causada pelo vírus do
epstein bar e é transmitida
principalmente pela saliva os sintomas
incluem dor de garganta fadiga mal-estar
febre e gangos inchados nos pescoço em
casos mais graves pode haver dor nas
articulações e no abdômen e até inchaço
no fígado ou no Basso a maioria das
pessoas se recupera mas a doença pode
ficar Adormecida no organismo em alguns
casos ser um gatilho para doenças
autoimunes